le président Poutine on vient de le voir
entouré de militaires et de char
pourtant son armée serait en train de le
tromper c'est ce qu'affirme vous gagnez
Prigogine le chef de Wagner en première
ligne dans la bataille de bataille de
barmut il accuse une nouvelle fois
l'état-major russe de ne pas le livrer
les munitions nécessaires pour prendre
la ville on l'écoute
il y a un crime en cours ça s'appelle
destruction du peuple russe et trahison
à la patrie un petit tas de personnes en
est responsable mais je suis sûr que le
contre espionnage militaire et les
services de sécurité vont trouver les
coupables
on a tendance le plus important c'est de
fournir tout le monde avec les munitions
qui reposent dans les stocks hier ils
ont fait une réunion où ils nous ont
accordé 10% de ce que nous demandions
ils nous ont menti et frontément on ne
quitte pas baroute on tiendra le bras de
fer pendant quelques jours encore
ensuite on verra
avec nous pour nous Darou en plateau
bonjour Bruno on est loin du défilé
glorieux tout à l'heure à Moscou oui
c'est vraiment le contre-pouvoir ou
l'autre côté du miroir comme on voudra
que ce discours de prix goji s'est
déclarations de trilogie d'autant plus
que il en a fait plusieurs il a fait
aussi une vidéo où il utilisait un
langage très très fleuri concernant les
coupables de ces errements évidemment il
désigne par là les responsables
hiérarchiques de l'armée russe si tout
est fait pour tromper le commandant en
chef c'est donc Vladimir Poutine alors
soit le commandant chef vous déchirera
le Cell je voilà Julien soit ce sera le
peuple russe qui sera furieux c'est la
guerre est perdue toujours un langage
très très fleuri et une nouvelle fois
des déclarations extrêmement hostile
vis-à-vis de la hiérarchie militaire
vous l'avez entendu il dit que
simplement 10% des munitions ont été
livrées alors concernant barmut vous
souvenez la semaine dernière il avait
dit nous si ça continue comme ça on
parle le 10 mai c'est-à-dire demain la
visiblement il a un peu repoussé son
ultimatum de quelques jours il dit on va
on va on va essayer de tenir encore
malgré ces manquements de l'armée russe
et il signale aussi que selon lui il y a
des soldats de l'armée russe des donc
régulière qui qui suit le front à
baroute et sous-entendu qu'il laisse
Wagner
seul face aux Ukrainiens donc
effectivement après c'est toujours la
question qui se pose pour comment
pourquoi lui peut faire de tels
déclarations on épargnant toujours vous
le voyez évidemment Vladimir Poutine
vous avez noté aussi qu'il dit que les
services de sécurité et le renseignement
militaire FSB Gru trouveront qui sont
les coupables et en tout cas il est
toujours dans ce dans ce bras de fer
mais qui est sans doute d'une certaine
manière autorisée par Vladimir Poutine
entre lui-même et sargame showgo le
minisol défense et Valérie girassimov le
chef d'état-major